في غضون ذلك تستمر اعمال رفع الانقاض
وترتفع معها حصيله القتلى اذ بلغت في
تركيا وحدها وفق احصاء كشفت عنه اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه 35 الفا
واربعمائه وثمانيه عشر قتيلا
بحسب المسؤولين الاتراك لتاجير مليونين
و200 الف شخص بينما نصبت عشرات الاف
الخيام في المناطق المنكوبه لايواء مئات
الالاف الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى
شبكه مراسلين من كهرمان مراش المعتز بلا
حسن
ومن اديمان سلام خضر سلام ابدا معك ما
الاولويه الان في في اليمن
البحث عن اي ناجي قد يكون لا يزال تحت
الانقاض الاولويه الثانيه الاهتمام
بالمصابين ومن يحتاجون الى متابعات لاحقه
لاصابتهم الاولويه الثالثه بطبيعه الحال
رفع عينات من المباني المنهاره تمهيدا
لازالتها وزاره العدل التركيه تؤكد انه لا
يتم رفع انقاض اي مبنى على الاطلاق من
المباني المدمره كليا الا بعد وصول فرق
مختصه لاخذ عينات لمعرفه السبب الذي ادى
الى انهيار هذا المبنى طبعا السبب المباشر
هو الزلزال ولكن يعني يحتاجون معرفه مدى
التزام الالتزام بمعايير البناء اثناء
انشاء هذه المباني التي انهارت يبدو انه
بحسب المعلومات وبحسب ما قال الرئيس
التركي غالبيه المباني التي انهارت يعود
انشاؤها الى ما قبل العام
ولم يكن هناك التزام كامل بمعايير البناء
المقاومه للزلازل لكن الانسان يبقى هو
الاهم الاول بالنسبه للسلطات التركيه
وعمال الانقاذ وايضا الجمعيات نحن في
واحده من المستشفيات الميدانيه العشرات من
المتطوعين يستمرون بالتوافد هنا هذا
المستشفى يقدم العلاج العمليات نحتاج
المريض الى اجراء اي عمليه وايضا صرف
ادويه للمتضررين جراء الزلزال هذا
المستشفى ايضا مختص بالدعم النفسي
وبالرعايه النفسيه
للناجين من الزلزال الاول والزلزال الثاني
الاطفال وايضا
البالغين هذا هو المستشفى الثاني في
المدينه طبعا مستشفيات اديمان تعمل ولكن
حجم الضرر الكبير الذي لحق بالمدينه حجم
او عدد الاصابات الكبير جدا في المدينه
حول المستشفيات الى اماكن مقتظه للغايه
وبات هناك حاجه الى دعم ميداني في
مستشفيات كهذه التي
ترونها ايضا هذه هؤلاء المتطوعين الذين
ترونهم في الصوره يقومون بجولات في ارجاء
المدينه يزورون ايضا المخيمات حيث تعيش
العائلات التي اضطرت لاخلاء منازلها
يطالعون على احتياجاتهم ان كانوا بحاجه
الى اي عنايه طبيه في المكان الذي هم في
هذه واحده من سيارات الاسعاف ستتحرك الان
في جوله جديده في ارجاء مدينه اديمان
وايضا كما ذكرنا في الاماكن ايواء
العائلات هذه الدوريات بين قوسين الطبيه
مستمره في المدينه اكثر من 300 سياره
اسعاف تعمل في اديمان للوقوف على احتياجات
السكان الطبيه وايضا الدعم النفسي يتم فيه
اماكن وجود مخيمات الايواء بحسب ما اكد
لنا الطبيب المسؤول عن هذا المستشفى
الميداني في اليمن جلال
ونتحول اليك
معتز بالله حسن كهرمان مرش ماء اولويات
الجهات الاغاثيه في هذا اليوم بعد مرور
عشره ايام على زازا
الاولويه في مدينه كهرمان مراش ما زالت
التاكد من عدم وجود اي احياء تحت الانقاض
ومن ثم
اغاثه الموجودين في الخارج هنا ربما هذه
المنطقه التي كانت قبل ايام ورشه عمل كبير
من اجل الانقاذ نحن نرى ان عمليات البحث
والمنقاذ في هذه المنطقه قد انتهت تماما
وهذا هو مركز مدينه كهرمان مراش كان هنا
ربما استطيع القول مئات من عمال الانقاذ
وعمال ازاله الانقاض موجودين نشاهد هناك
ربما بعض الاشخاص الذين
ما زالوا يبحثون ربما في انقاض البيوت عن
شيء ما هناك نشاهد وجود
معتز بالله حسن وسلام خضر شكرا جزيلا لكم